hello you're watching Sky News breakfast
thanks for being with us the Ukrainian
president has delivered a wartime
message of defiance and thanks in an
address to the U.S Congress overnight
Vladimir zielinski's trip to Washington
was his first time abroad since Russia
invaded Ukraine back in February the U.S
President Joe Biden has promised
zelenski billions more dollars in Aid as
well as a patriot missile system our U.S
correspondent James Matthews has our top
story president of Ukraine
it was Rockstar stuff the acclaimed the
president dressed in khaki
Crash from the war zone to The Well of
the house chamber with an assessment
from the front line
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
you might not have spotted the
Republicans who sat when everyone else
stood but he did address concerns over
usaid to Ukraine it wasn't charity he
said but an investment for his country
and for theirs he spoke of a turning
point in 2023 next year will be a
turning point I know it the point when
Ukrainian courage and American resolve
director of our common freedom
earlier in the day at the White House
there had been a comforting hand from
the president and a handout you are the
man of the year to the Ukrainian he
hailed as U.S Man Of The Year the U.S
president pledged a patriot missile
defense system we're in a continuous
strength of Ukraine's ability to defend
itself particularly air defense and
that's why we're going to be providing
Ukraine with Patriot missile battery
zelenski's first foreign trip since
conflict began took place amidst the
tightest security it began in darkness
at the Polish border and continued in a
U.S military plane under escort by NATO
Jets
the reassurance he received here of
continued support will matter to
president zielinski what will matter
more is the Pledge of military hardware
he takes home specifically Patriot
missiles a defensive Shield as Russia
targets his country's infrastructure
from the air
zelenski isn't the first wartime leader
in Wartime to address a joint session of
Congress Winston Churchill came before
him in 1941 during the second World War
there was no Handover of a battlefield
flag in his day the choreography might
have changed in 81 years but warnings of
tyranny remain the same
James Matthews Sky News Washington
let's go to Ukraine now bring in our
International Affairs editor Dominic
waccone who is in Odessa for us good
morning to you Dominic so a huge moment
last night in Congress as zelenski
addressed Congress people and that
promise of money and of course that
missile system will be well received
yes but not enough I think is is what
ukrainians will feel here um and I think
they are frustrated that people in the
west haven't really quite got the
measure of what's Happening Here and
what could happen over the winter we
went to the town of backwards uh which
is where the fiercest battle in this War
uh is being waged now
um it's a town where the Russians have
made considerable advances despite
Ukrainian resistance they control High
Ground some of The High Ground around
the city so we had to drive in Fast on
back roads to avoid the uh the threat of
artillery far in our vehicles and once
you get into the town you hear this
regular constant sound of shelling
nearby it's a clear sense we weren't
that far from the front line of the
battle that's raging there we met some
Chechen fighters who are hard to get to
film but they invited us to their secret
bunker there and their insights into
this War I think were very revealing and
worth listening to in the west and what
they say is the Russians are using the
tactics they've been using against
enemies like the Chechen since the 90s
the age-old Russian tactics of using
quantity over quality a lot of
conscripts coming in wave after wave in
backwards they're not well trained
they're not well armed they're not very
motivated they're being ordered from the
rear but they're being sent in such
waves that despite the Ukrainian
resistance the spirit of the fighters
and the weapons that begin being given
by the West they are grindingly making
their way into the City and that's what
ukrainians are up against they they're
undoubtedly Brave determined and
spirited but they need more weapons they
need more advanced weapons they say
because the Russians are now uh doubling
down on this we heard Putin yesterday
say that he wants to expand the Army to
1.5 million soldiers so he's going to
use this sort of human wave strategy to
try and ground down the ukrainians and
what they're saying here is they need
more weapons to see that off the other
thing that's very clear from here when
you drive through the cities here that
one after another are plunged Into
Darkness is that the West is not doing
enough to repel the threats of the
Russians degrazing ukrainians power
grids here and that is a mortal danger
to ukrainians it could risk many of them
dying freezing to death in the homes
over winter and you get a sense it's
cold now but it's going to get much
colder here when you drive through these
cities which are plunged Into Darkness
if that continues it's going to kill
ukrainians but it's also going to sap
the morale and fighting spirits of
ukrainians fighting on the front and the
West has got to do more to repel that
threat and frankly ukrainians say that
the Patriots battery they've been asking
for for months which they're finally
getting won't be enough and it's not
very good at taking out the kind of
Cheaper plentiful drones that the
Russians are sending against them that
they're buying from uh from Iran so more
needs to be done I think they'll be
buoyed by the kind of reception that
their president had in Washington but
they will I think be frustrated that
they're still not getting enough and
very wide by what President Biden said
when he's asked why not more advanced
referee was being given to the Ukraine
and he said he's having to weigh up the
ukrainians military needs with the need
to keep the Alliance United and I think
that will be music to Putin's ears the
president's articulating there but there
are still division Asians in the
alliance about what kind of weapons the
ukrainians can be given okay Dominic for
now thank you very much
now back here and the disruption is far
from over is the warning this morning
from Health leaders after yesterday's
strike by ambulance stuff NHS providers
says that the knock on effects are
likely to mean some challenging days
ahead for stretch services and as unions
and ministers remain locked in stalemate
overpay negotiations it's being reported
that the government could try and speed
up an NHS pay deal next year Cindy
marike reports
called to the front line of a crisis
but not the kind you'd usually associate
them with
members of the military responding to
ambulance call outs to plug the gaps
left by staff from the picket line
[Applause]
thousands of call handlers paramedics
technicians and more out in force and
with the support of these people at
least
do you know what I mean they're doing a
good job it's not easy they put up all
types of stuff going on abuse and
everything but that the money is no good
it's no good if a footballer can earn
what they can earn I'll look at it that
they can earn earn a lot not a lot more
but earn double than what they're
earning now
the London Ambulance Service one of
those was staff on strike yesterday the
vehicles you can see behind me were left
providing what's been described as life
and limb cover responding to only the
most serious emergency calls that's part
of a pay dispute with very real
consequences for the public and another
strike date to come next week
NHS leaders have warned the disruption
to care or continue
999 calls in parts of the country were
down suggesting some people chose to
stay away potentially making their
conditions worse
here at this care home in Bristol there
was an emergency call for a resident who
thought they might be having a heart
attack the operator because of the
strikes she said that we needed to use
the defibrillator from the local pub
unfortunately we can't just go and get
that we have to contact the local pub
first to say that we need it then they
said we then just contact the GP so
that's what we've done so it wasn't a
heart attack thankfully but you know it
puts you in that position what if it was
that incident could have been much worse
the government and unions failing to get
around the table could be fatal for some
headlines today suggest ministers are
thinking about pay recommendations for
next year
with more strike action planned for next
week
people will be hoping all parties can
take the heat away from this industrial
dispute
because Deadlocks involving an already
stretched Health Service are the ones
that will hurt the most shinki marike
Sky News Royal London Hospital
all right let's bring in the Becky
cultural who's outside of Thomas's
Hospital in central London's for us
right now good morning again to you
Becky so what's the situation there now
well I think really all eyes within the
Health Service here and throughout the
country will be on a e departments today
and in the coming days as you heard in
shingy's report then uh calls to
ambulances 999 calls were down yesterday
and that is likely because people who
did need care he did those warnings to
only call for an ambulance if your life
was at risk but that doesn't mean that
those people don't need medical
attention and the concern is that their
conditions may have deteriorated because
they didn't get that care when they
should have done it's not just a Fallout
from the ambulance strikes though that
the Health Service and patients are
dealing with it's also the nurses
strikes one earlier this week and also
one last week and we know that for this
week's strike alone there are almost 13
800 appointments canceled or rescheduled
and that is adding to this big backlog
of procedures that built up throughout
the pandemic now unions and striking
staff would say well that backlog wait
times including in emergency care they
were all building up anyway because so
many staff are leaving the Health
Service because of pay and working
conditions and that is why they are now
having to strike but I think
particularly in terms of the Fallout
from yesterday's ambulance strike the
focus and the concern will be on
patients showing up at a e departments
critically ill because they didn't get
the care they needed yesterday
Becky thank you for now let's bring in
our political correspondent Ali patasku
who's joining us for more on this so Ali
where are we with negotiations between
the unions and the government right now
well the government had been accused of
taking a hard line it has felt this week
like the prospect of a deal between the
government and the unions has been
Vanishing into the distance certainly I
think we've seen a hardening of the
rhetoric from both sides
um but the front page of the telegraph
this morning talking about a new deal
when it comes to NHS workers my
understanding from the conversations
that I've had is that there's no
Prospect of a kind of immediate New Deal
that would solve the problem of strike
action right now but the health
secretary is very keen to make the
process of making recommendations with
the pay review body that sets pay for
public sector pay next year happen as
quickly as possible ordinarily they are
meant to set pay in about April that
process has been delayed in previous
years there is a desire from the health
secretary to look forward to make sure
that that process happens as quickly as
possible but this is not a sort of last
minute Chris Christmas miracle that will
stop the strikes from happening it will
not avert the prospect of ambulance
strikes next week more nurses strikes
expected next year
um so of course both sides saying that
the other needs to budge and the the
problem for the prime minister is that
this is starting to reflect not just on
the health secretary but on him too
accusations that he hasn't been seen
that he's shirking responsibility others
will say he's trying to not look weak
and talk tough on the unions it is an
uncomfortable Dynamic the government
being pitted against workers as public
sympathy starts to wane I think there is
a potential for the blame to end up at
the government's feet for this but I
think it is fair to say that there is no
sign of a a deal that is going to have
an immediate impact today and that means
that more strike action looms and that's
going to have an impact on everyone
it certainly is okay Ali for now thank
you
and just to let you know that later this
hour will be speaking to the interim
chief executive of NHS providers saffron
caudry that is at half past seven
now NHS strikes are just part of a wave
of industrial action that's taking place
this month the rmt rail Union is going
to Stage another walkout from Christmas
Eve until the morning of December the
27th there are currently no further
nursing strikes planned after their walk
out earlier this week ambulance workers
will be on strike on the 28th of
December
rural mail workers will be back on the
picket line tomorrow and on Saturday
Christmas Eve border force staff are
going to walk off the job from tomorrow
to the 26th and then again from the 28th
to the 31st
and workers from National highways are
also striking today they're members of
the public and Commercial Services Union
in London and Southeast England will be
off work until Christmas day then in the
West Midlands and Southwest on the 31st
and 30th
all right let's return now to president
of Vladimir zielinski's first trip
abroad since Russia invaded Ukraine he's
been to Washington as we said and has
met with President Biden and spoken
before Congress now so Peter westmorcott
is a former British ambassador to the
United States and joins us now live so
Peter good morning to you thank you very
much for being with us on Sky news this
morning
um we'll get some
um some of the specifics of the details
of the visit but first just give us a
sense of the significance of of him
actually going there and speaking uh to
Congress
I think it's a very important moment you
remember when this terrible innovation
of Ukraine began and the Americans
offered a plane to get zelenski out of
Ukraine because their military just like
a lot of the military here and elsewhere
I didn't think the ukrainians were going
to last more than a few days and the
response of zelenski was I don't need a
trip I need ammunition so he's been very
clear from the beginning that he needed
foreign military support and to their
great credit the Americans have given
him something like 50 billion dollars
worth of support much of that military
some of it for natural over the last
nine or ten months you know far far more
than anybody else has and so to go to
Washington uh when there was a little
bit of a law on the fighting to make his
case uh before Congress and with that
resonance which Dominic was mentioning
of the way in which Winston Churchill
went to Congress at Christmas in 1941 I
think that's not lost on a lot of people
including speaker Pelosi I think
optically and symbolically it's a great
time to go there but on the material
side I I think it's important too
because Congress is about to change
hands at least the the House of
Representatives is and Republicans are
going to take over the leadership they
will be harder to persuade to provide
Ukraine with lots more assistance next
year so the fact that sometime the next
day or two we hope there's going to be a
vote for another 45 billion dollars
worth of support for Ukraine with this
Congress is really important for Ukraine
because if it's this time next year God
forbid it's not going to be quite as
easy because there'll be different
leadership on the hill and there may be
a degree of Ukraine fatigue setting in
yeah and you say difficult to persuade I
mean there are some commentators who
think that perhaps President silenci
should have gone in a couple of months
time when that new Congress is in I mean
genuine concerns then are there sir
Peter that a new Congress might not have
the full might not give their full
support to Ukrainian president zielinski
going forward I think in the Senate it's
okay I was in Washington 10 days ago I
spoke to Republicans and to Democrats in
the Senate and there there is still
strong by partisan support for America
doing its bit to support Ukraine against
this this brutal murderous Invasion the
house is going to change hands there
will be Republican leadership there are
some wobbles there not entirely but um I
think it's going to be a bit more
difficult in the House of
Representatives if not in the Senate so
I think getting through the current
defense Appropriations bill which has to
be voted through in the next few days is
critical and it's it's I think in my
view good politics because zelinski to
be there at this time let's deal with
the problems for the next Congress when
that arises but he desperately needs
that Military Support now the Patriots
and other things because we know what
Putin is up to he's trying to destroy
the infrastructure destroy the destroy
the will of the Ukrainian people and
then issue completely unacceptable terms
for some sort of armistice and so
Ukraine needs the support of its friends
and allies to resist those efforts from
Putin let's come on to the Patriot
battery system that's going to be sent
then to people I mean when Joe Biden
talked about it it did sound like you
said Patriot battery singular so is it
just one system do we know yet but
that's not the only weapon system that's
going to be sent is it there is a there
are more weapons being sent to help try
and defend Ukrainian Skies
well Patriots come in track loads of
four I'm not a military expert as you
know
um how many do you get for whether 1.8
billion which is firmly committed before
the big vote coming up at the next day
or two I'm not sure I think I heard
Patriots in the plural but of course
they're not all that they need Patriots
are expensive missiles which shoot down
high-flying bombers and fighter aircraft
they're not a very efficient way of
dealing with cheap and cheerful uh
drones which Putin has got from his
friends in Iran so they do need other
military equipment to support themselves
and they need a lot of ammunition they
need more artillery they need a whole
lot of different bits of military
equipment there's no doubting the
Readiness and the willingness of the
Ukrainian soldiers to fight well trained
including by the British by the way over
the last eight or nine years they've
defied expectations but they do need
more care of a whole lot of different
varieties and so Peter let me just
expand this a little bit if I can then
look at NATO support more broadly and I
want you to see if you can put your
former ambassador to Turkey hat on for a
minute just how tricky is it managing
the relationship right now between NATO
and the largest military in NATO uh
Turkey
um in terms of that grain deal with
erdogan in charge and also NATO's
expansion
well Kabbalah you know turkey as well I
know that you were president of Istanbul
some time back look I think that
president erdogan is playing a pretty
clever game in that he remains in touch
with both sides turkey has no desire to
see Russia take control of Ukraine and
therefore of the Black Sea which is
after all its own backyard and it's
behaved pretty responsibly in denying
access to the streets through Bosphorus
through Istanbul to Russian warships as
a belligerent State as the language goes
but uh and and also I should say that
turkey is providing some very useful
drugs to Ukraine but it's doing quite
well from the position of being in touch
with both sides not having sanctioned
Russia it has become an indispensable
neighbor and it may well play a role if
there is to be or when there is to be
some sort of a diplomatic conversation
but in the meantime because it's not
sanctioning Russia masses of money is
coming from Russia into the Turkish
economy which is one of the reasons why
for the last few months very unusually
the Turkish lira has remained state
table rather than continued the Free
Fall that we've seen over the last year
or two so turkey's playing clever hand
doing quite well from the present
situation but has yet to play I think a
potentially important role when the
diplomacy comes into play
and while I have you so Peter just a
very last thought here and this is uh
off topic entirely of the war in
Ukrainian and about Israel and about the
new Administration that's been formed
there I mean that there are set the
leaders in key positions in the
government now of Benjamin netaji's new
Administration is any hope even the
Trump Kushner deal is that now
completely overdo you think
well I think the Abraham Accords are
still there uh of course they haven't
yet got Saudi Arabia signing on to them
but that is a diplomatic achievement
rather surprising one because it wasn't
quite what Jerry Kushner was initially
uh selling but what I certainly have
heard in Washington is some concern that
a new Netanyahu government with some
very uh hard-line right-wing uh
Coalition Partners may be more difficult
in terms of Palestinian rights which is
something that's been relatively quiet
for a while and I know that there are
some people in Washington who are
nervous that Israel might become yet
more hawkish about Iran because of
course president Trump tore up the
nuclear deal that we had which
constrained Iran's ability to develop
nuclear weapons so I I know that there
are some foreign policy specialists in
Washington who are looking with some
concern about what's going to happen in
Israel and the extent to which some of
those Hawks may try and drag America
into a harder line both on Palestinian
issues and on dealing with the Iranian
nuclear threat okay so Peter Westman got
really good to have your thoughts this
morning to appreciate your time and your
patience thanks for being with us thank
you
now businesses say they feel like
they're banging their heads against a
brick wall over improving a trade with
the European Union that's according to
the British Chambers of Commerce which
says its members are still struggling
with the UK's post-brexit trading
Arrangements now in a survey They
carried out it found that more than half
of its members were finding it difficult
to comply with new rules for exporting
Goods while 45 reported problems with
adapting to rules for trading services
and the vast majority 77 so the deal
hadn't helped them increase sales
all right let's start with some start
this section here with some breaking
news that's coming in the last couple of
minutes the UK economy contracted by
more than had been bought in the third
quarter of this year the latest figures
that have come from the office for
National statistics show that the fall
in GDP was in fact 0.3 we'll have more
on those new GDP figures throughout the
morning here on Sky News Now there could
be more disruption in the new year with
doctors in Wales who are considering
strike action for the first time the
British Medical Association Welsh
Council says it spoke to Hospital
doctors this month and found that almost
two-thirds are in favor of some kind of
industrial action the union says the
government needs to finally wake up to
the crisis
and we're just saying with sir Peter uh
Benjamin Netanyahu says he's formed a
new Coalition allowing him to return to
Israel's prime minister he's leading the
most right-wing government Israel has
ever seen dominated by far-right
ultra-orthodox parties the newly
appointed security minister was once
convicted of incitement to racism and of
supporting a terror group
and gender reform legislation in
Scotland is expected to pass in a final
vote at Hollywood later after being
delayed last night the bill will lower
to 16 the minimum age which a person can
legally change their gender it was set
to be voted on a Wednesday but long
debates over amendments pushed the vote
back to this afternoon
the former boss of the bankrupt crypto
exchange FTX has been extradited to the
United States to face criminal charges
Sam bankman freed who was arrested in
the Bahamas is likely to face a judge in
New York today prosecutors say that two
Associates of bankman free have pleaded
guilty to charges in cooperation for a
deal
and the Brazilian football legend Pele
it will remain in hospital over
Christmas after doctors found that his
cancer had Advanced the 82 year old's
been undergoing chemotherapy since
having a tumor removed from his colon
last year
and the King will continue to tradition
of having a birthday parade in the
summer trooping the color will be held
on the 17th of June in central London
his actual birthday as you know it's the
14th of November the queen consort and
other members of the royal family will
be stepping up for ceremonial military
roles
hello and welcome back you're watching
Sky News breakfast let's return now to
those strikes in the NHS and the
warnings from Health leaders the
disruption is far from over I'm joined
Now by The Internship executive of NHS
providers staff from cordray a saffron
Cody good morning to you and thank you
so much for being with us so NHS leaders
saying the disruption is far from over
what are the next couple of days and
weeks going to be like
I think we're in for um a challenging
time over the next couple of days
because what we do know is after this
kind of strike action or after something
like a bank holiday in the NHS we know
that there is a lot of pent-up demands
so although yesterday with the ambulance
service strikes things perhaps the
demand was down what we are going to see
now is demand really Rising so I think
emergency departments particularly are
going to feel the strain in those areas
where there were strikes which for
ambulance services was in every part of
the country apart from the east of
England so some real pressure there
pent-up demand and also the added
pressure of rearranging all of those
operations and appointments that needed
to be postponed and what's that going to
mean for patient safety
I think we we should be assured that
that leaders would do everything that
they can to make sure that patients
remain as safe as possible so that will
mean making sure that there are as many
staff as possible in those emergency
departments and making sure that
those operations can be
rearranged for as quickly as possible so
yeah it's going to be a challenging time
but the one thing that's really
important for the public and patients to
understand is that trust leaders do
everything in their power to to make
sure that patients are kept as safe as
possible I mean you mentioned it being
sort of the bounce back afterwards like
a bank holiday but you'll know
anecdotally many people who work in the
NHS say Staffing levels mean that every
day is almost like a bank holiday
because they are so understaffed I mean
where does this get resolved at this
point do you think now
I think you're absolutely right in terms
of those fundamental levels of Staff
shortages these structural issues that
we talk about stuff on the front line
are are significantly overstretched and
we need to see a real growth in the
number of Staff across the whole of the
NHS what we've got to see now is the
government come to the table and have a
serious discussion and negotiation about
pay because this dispute is about pay
and it's also about working conditions
and keeping patients safe and we know
what they're going to say about pay
that's for the independent pay review
board but let's talk about the working
conditions
I took a look at the um NHS provider's
website it says one of the missions is
to provide builds effective
relationships with central government
key stakeholders in central government
is there any feeling among energy
providers that that relationship has not
been working functionally after all this
time that we've reached this point
no I don't think that's fair to say our
role is to make sure that the government
understands the impact of its policies
and seek to encourage it to improve
those policies in the interests of the
NHS and the patients that it it it's
there to treat so I don't I wouldn't say
that they're broken down in in any way
we're there to really you know nudge
them and keep them going and focused on
on on the task in hand so we will
continue to do that and I think that
after the significant disruption we saw
last week
um and this week and we're going to see
next week with with the ambulance strike
again and the possibility of strikes
being announced in in the new year I
think what we've got to do is make sure
that we stay completely focused on
making sure that the government
understands the importance of coming to
the table and understands the importance
of making sure that we're in a situation
where we can boost the level of Staffing
across the HS and also make sure that
Frontline staff get the pay terms and
conditions they deserve and I'm not
trying to be unfair as suffering as
you'll understand but I do want you say
nudge them I wonder if all sizes need a
bit more of a shove
my choice of language there was
something yeah
absolutely about being very clear about
the impact of what is going on at the
moment where that's come from and what
we actually need to do in future to make
sure that we have adequate Staffing
across the NHS we know that there are a
hundred and thirty thousand well more
than 130
000 vacancies in the NHS we know that we
are hemorrhaging staff because of pay
and working conditions particularly in
more Junior bands of NHS staff so we
really have to do something about that
and it's not just about the NHS the
government knows we need to do something
about social care as well because social
care is really on its knees and it needs
a boost and if the if social care has a
boost then the NHS Frontline staff have
the terms and conditions they need then
we will see an effective NHS yeah and it
comes down to funding again doesn't it I
mean the uh Health sector yesterday was
talking about extra funding to improve
outcomes and treatments but without
having a staff to to carry out those
treatments and services you're not going
to be able to a functioning service I
mean how much more money does social
care need to to get it functioning to
then help the health care sector I think
social care needs a very significant
cash injection and it needs also some
structural funding Support over a
significant period of time the way that
social care is funded is very much
there's there's a central funding pot
but then is also social care is funded
through local council tax so it's up to
the discretion of local councils as to
how high they set their What's called
the social care precept so it's it's a
very variable funding source so I think
we we need to see some significant focus
on that to make sure that it's
sustainable and fit for purpose and we
know that that local government has
struggled over the years with with
funding that has been depleted by up to
60 over the last 10 years or so so
that's very very difficult to run the
high level of services that they need to
run to support social care in children
in adults in vulnerable adults and older
people and you know that's a tough task
for them yeah and finally then saffron
quadri with all that we're facing in the
Health Service
um how worried are you about how it's
going to fare through this winter
we've known even
what the industrial action we we knew
that we were in for a a tough time and
NHS Frontline stuff are incredibly
ingenious they are incredibly creative
Innovative trust leaders will be doing
all that they can to put plans in place
and we know that they work very closely
with NHS England and others to do that
but it's going to be hard demand is very
high Staffing levels aren't where they
should be and we know that we've got flu
which is causing Rising levels of
hospitalizations we've got mental health
waiting lists which is going through the
roof we've got covid coming back now and
we've just had a really cold snap so if
we have another one of those that's
going to add into the pot so we are
seeing a really tough situation here I
mean NHS staff will do everything they
can to get through this and to support
patients and to provide a safer care as
possible but we know it's going to be
tough
okay suffering quotery uh internship
exec of NHS providers do appreciate your
time this morning thank you very much
thank you
all right let's take a look at the
weather now because we're getting a
clearer picture of how it's going to
look in time for Christmas after a
increase in temperatures at the start of
this week let's bring in Kirsty McKay
bar meteorologist for some more on this
so Kirsty how the next couple of days
looking weather-wise
morning Kamali is looking very unsettled
actually from also as much milder than
it was a bit of a disappointment I have
to see after that cold snap I think many
people had hoped for a white Christmas
not looking so likely now and if you're
interested a white Christmas officially
it's when a single flake of snow is
observed falling from the sky during the
24 hours of Christmas day now there is
of course a chance that will happen
somewhere most likely the northwest of
Scotland and we will see colder air
coming in later on on Christmas but that
idea of a blanket of snow on the ground
well that's not looking likely this
Christmas but let's take a look at
what's happening in the run-up
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it is going to be quite mild and
changeable then some wet conditions in
the run-up to Christmas Colder Weather
returning from the north though
Christmas Day evening into Boxing Day
bit of a murky gray start this morning
there's some fog patches around across
parts of England and Wales and Ireland
two rather green Misty there's some
overnight rain and drizzle still
lingering further north is a brighter
start but here is a little bit colder
with a few scattered wintry showers and
a touch of frost it is going to stay
pretty gray and murky across England and
Wales for other outbreaks of rain and
drizzle at times Scotland Northern
Ireland and Northern parts of Ireland I
think generally looking a little bit
brighter with a few scattered showers in
that Northerly wind now it is going to
turn a bit colder from the north through
the day we'll see a few of those showers
in the far north turning wintry and
there's always a threat to some heavier
rain at times just clipping the far
south of England but generally looking a
little bit drier into the evening again
could see a return of some fog patches
as we go through the night quite damp
and drizzly in the South and a more
persistent band of rain pushing in from
the south west later to the north you'll
notice things getting colder across
Northern Scotland Friday's going to be a
busy day for traveling so worth bearing
in mind this band of rain sweeping up
from the southwest it could be Heavy at
times the wind's freshening as well and
where the rain bumps into the colder air
in the north it could be some snow
mainly over Northern Hills
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
we'll take a closer look in a moment at
the stories that are dominating the
morning's newspapers
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk
[Music]
in Europe
after a week of largely dry weather
across the Alps things are now cooling
from the north with some lights to
moderate snowfall many Austrian resorts
are open with fresh nojew in the next
few days the deepest reported snow
depths around the two meter Mark and
that's in the southern French Alps Italy
is also doing well with 85 centimeters
of snow at the base of the bardenetia
ski area and the ski resorts in
Switzerland haven't had snow for some
days but expect some fresh snow this
week
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk online ski hire in Europe
hello and welcome back let's take a look
through the morning's newspapers we've
got the editor of Birmingham live and
the Birmingham Mel Graham Brown and the
writer Benedict Spence all right guys
let's get straight into this then we'll
go to the front page of the Daily Mail
to start with I think we'll start off
with you Benedict if that is all right
and just tell us about the reporting
here on the front of the mail about
petrol pricing
yes this is uh tremendously upbeat news
to go with everything else that's very
positive this morning and that is that
uh on you know in addition to uh there's
uh train strikes across the country
there's uh Railway companies saying that
people shouldn't travel unless it's
absolutely essential and talk of
potential uh strikes at airports causing
chaos uh this is the news that it's
gonna cost a lot more uh it is currently
costing a lot more simply to fill up
your car
um and obviously the mail is leading on
the line that it's going to make
Christmas a lot more difficult but um
the RAC say that the average cost of
filling up on diesel is about 15 just
under 15 pounds more expensive than it
was last year and that petrol is about
four pounds but the key thing here is is
that it's about uh petrol is about seven
Pence more than it was this time last
year per liter and the RAC say that it
should be 15 Pence less and the reason
why this is uh this is uh the major
supermarkets the four major supermarkets
in this country
where you can often go and fill up as
you do your groceries they are refusing
to pass on drops in the average cost the
wholesale price of fuel uh which are
being seen at smaller independent um
petrol stations so if you go to an
independent one you're more likely to to
save money than if you go to a
supermarket
um obviously this has a you know a very
big impact
um on people but supposedly yeah this is
at least in part because uh supermarkets
are losing money across the board on
other aspects where you know uh changes
in prices haven't been passed on uh so
food production basically cost of
transporting food uh and all the rest of
it so it's a bit of a difficult one
really obviously supermarkets need to
make you know make some profit or at the
very least keep their margins and they
are running quite tight margins as it is
anyway and it seems that uh you know
where they are potentially making losses
on food they're trying to catch up on
things like fuel yeah absolutely it's
amazing I've noticed the difference from
what it was 180 earlier this year to be
in about 150 now but um I guess as
somebody else said it should get cheaper
than that right Graham let's let's keep
moving on we're going to go to a story
inside the guardian and this is about
Twitter Chief Twitter Elon Musk is going
to stay on even though he lost his poll
as boss until he finds a replacement
yeah
Elon musky said he's he's perhaps the
most entertaining thing on Twitch at the
moment um so yes he put out this policy
it's very keen on um on allowing people
to decide the future off of Twitter
itself potentially they say the things
that he doesn't want to hear
um yeah so he put out this probably of
the day I think 57 of people said that
that Elon Musk should go meanwhile uh
Snoop Dogg came along later and 83 of
people apparently think that he should
that he should run Twitter
um it appears like he's he's now
relented on his his love of democracy
and he's potentially going to continue
to run Twitter and I think I don't know
whether that's good news for Twitter but
it's good news for the entertainment of
people watching it it certainly is
entertaining I wonder how strong that
love of democracy was in the first place
let's keep moving on uh Benedict and
we're going to go to this one which I
hopefully uh it's gonna make us smile a
little bit this is uh the uh education
Century Jillian Keegan who was filmed on
this very Channel wearing a Rolex and
now she's hit back at what she's calling
inverted snobs
yeah I um it was a bit sort of surprised
by this uh everybody very legalized
eagleized viewers watch seeing how much
uh somebody's watch cost uh look I mean
we all understand why this sort of thing
would make the papers you know sort of
cost a living crisis everybody's going
to sort of leap to look at how much it
is the government ministers are spending
but you know it does seem a little
unfair to jump on somebody for something
that could have been purchased at any
time
um you know potentially could have been
inherited I don't know what the
situation is for Mrs Keegan yeah I don't
have a ten thousand pound watch
um I'd feel very upset if people
criticized me if I had a ten thousand
pound watch and I felt that I worked
very hard for it
um you know they people should go get
the bag it's very important to be able
to tell time if you're a minister
sometimes you don't have your phone yeah
you always need a backup and you're okay
if it's going to cost you ten thousand
pounds that seems a little pricey but
that is what you choose to spend your
money on well yeah fair enough it's to
be expensive with that yeah and it seems
better than spending it on petrol put it
that way yeah as someone who just got a
new watch I do like looking at my wrist
and seeing the time rather than looking
at my phone and there's a there's a
great little uh pulled out quote here in
the in the May male ground that says
opened many doors for me I mean if the
watch is opening doors that is a really
cool watch
yeah it's interesting actually how Mrs
cake has dealt with she's not she's not
your usual tourist she's very cute for
people to know because she uh she let's
call it 16 and
um and went through an apprenticeship
and so on she's trying to make it's a
thing about inverted snobbery and about
um about credit working class aspiration
I think in practice what this really is
is that yeah she's education secretary
people are asking for um
history dictates that's probably not
necessarily going to happen and whether
or not the Optics of wearing a ten
thousand pound Rolex at this point is
necessarily the smartest thing to do
yeah perhaps not right great embedded
it's really good to have you guys again
sorry that was so short we'll have more
time with you hopefully next hour thank
you very much speech again soon